E
D
FO T
ORENT'S ANNUAL PHYSIIN BACK C
L
R. SANJAY GU T MR ACTUALLY DENI
REPORTING BUT THEY ARE DENYING
WHAT SAY THE
REPORTING.
THOUGH I H
LEGITIMATEUT REPORT WTTHE PRESI
SAID THEY WER  OF HAVING
ROKES.
THAT
POSITION TO THEN P A
STEMENT WHICHEE DIRENT TRUHE SA
CONFIRM HE HAS NOT EXPERIENCED
OR BEEN EVALUATED FORA MIN
R
CARDIOVASCULAR.OTEN THE VICE PRT
THIS ABRUPT TRIPOTE THERE COUL.
CKY WAS ONCE PUT O  GEORGE OP VS
TRIP WAS FOR THE EXCTHSAID HE
LATERPRIL OF0 WHEN THEY
THEN LEASED THE RF IT.
>> R THAT
WE WHEN HE  KAITLAN.
ONHI T
ALL SCRAMBLING TO FIGURE OUT,
OKAY, WHAT I GOING ON,  AS PRESE
DOSERPO
THAT TRESINTAV WERE REALLY SPEC
PROCURD REQUIRE GHIG. WHAT HE D
DO
EYHE
DID HAVE DONE.
SOS ONE THESE THINGS
WHWE
WOWH W
POINTED OUT, THIS WAS AN UNUSUAL
I HAVE COVERED FOUR DIERIDENTS
WITH THE NOTY ITAS QUICK
UNPLANNED SORT OF VISIT.
I WILL SAY THIS BACK AND LEDIS D
S IN THE HOSPITAORVER UR'T LONG.
THEDEA THATHI  KIND OF ANESTHES
SOMETHING LIKE HE PROBABLY
WOVE BTAL
LONGER.
IT'S T T THERESOMETHING THAT WAS
WHILEWA THERE?  KY, N
REQUIRT O D
TH EITHER.
>> WELL, LET'S TOUEE VICE PR BE
JUST A SCENA B STING
PROCEDURE?
DON'T THINK SO.ITLAN MENTIONED
RW THE TWENTY-FIFTH
AMENDMENT WAS DRAWN UP IN 20AS R
CO SORT OF PROTOCOL BACK
WHREAGAN, THE TWENTY-FIFTH
AMENDM P DRAWN UP THAT TIME AS
THUCLF CAN DO A LOT O GSEYREAD
LABS DONE THAT DAY.THE PRESIDE .
YOURSELF WHAT WALTER REAS
OFFERING AHAT THEMEDICAL UNIT C
NO OFFER?
>> ANDALSO, SANJAY IS CORRECT
THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE TO TELL US
AT ON.PRESIDENT' H IS
MPORTANTOR VOTERSO
KNOW WHAT'S ON.
IT'S EIANT WHEN
ITD TRUMP WHO HASREO DOUBTST JO
THE LAST SEVUTT BEENGTASBOUT. W
E PAST SEEM T  HIS HEALTH.
IT'S ALWAYN THING, HIS DOCTORS.R
ADT THE HEALTH AND THE FITNESS
OF THERESIDE WE TALK ABOUT THE
OU WHO HAS
ENORMOUS POWER IF THERE'S
SOMETHING GOING ON THAT'SFBI
FUNCTION, THAT BE,HI KNOW.
AGAIHE NATKNOW, BUTPL
WANT TO KNOWU'RIGHT.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHTTHERE HA
D OROLIC.
HE WOULD UNEQUIVOCALHEALTHIEST Y
HOUSE.
THERE L00 OLD.THERE IS ALL THE
JUST YOU WONDERHO I ON WITH THET
BA SWEART BUT THE W
E THAT UN ASKED ABOUTORTANTT.'SR